il a d'abord eu lure où l'on a dû
abattre dix millions de volailles
domestiques puis les états unis
l'alberta l'ontario et maintenant le
québec la grippe aviaire est à nos
portes c'est quelque chose qui nous
préoccupe à noter
que nous devinons
canada pour l'instant l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments ne
parle que d'un seul cas possible au
québec en attente de confirmation
la semaine dernière on a identifié trois
cas de grippe chez des oiseaux sauvages
dans ceux du québec
c'est peu mais la menace est sérieuse il
n'existe pas de traitement pour cette
maladie est mortelle t élevé qui se
répand comme une traînée de poudre on a
une souche h5n1 qui ne ne cause pas de
maladie chez l'être humain mais qui
affecte beaucoup les oiseaux et qui est
traité par les oiseaux malades fait que
l'environnement est très contaminée la
meilleure protection pour les éleveurs
la désinfection constant de l'équipement
à l'entrée et à la sortie des bâtiments
d'élevage
est très important plus on peut réagir
parce qu'on a des plans d'intervention
puis on peut le faire rapidement mieux
les chances de pouvoir conventionnés le
problème dans l'industrie québécoise la
volaille qui regroupe plus de 700
producteurs où s'affairent depuis
plusieurs semaines informer les membres
et à sécuriser les installations nous
oppose à loire ont toutes été avertis
soit par des liens avec les mots qu'on
donne des conférences deux
reprises par semaine chez les petits
producteurs certifiés bio l'enjeu est
différent comme on a une production
diversifiée avec plusieurs productions
différentes on n'a pas mis sans mon
raisonnement tout l'enjeu dans le même
panier sa crainte c'est d'être obligés
d'enfermer ses volailles comme tous les
producteurs français doivent maintenant
le faire imaginons que par exemple
pendant toute la saison estivale moi je
peux pas je peux pas les sortir à
l'extérieur
moi je peux pour maintenir ma
certification biologique par exemple
pour les animaux le savent donc ça veut
dire ma production de volailles en tant
qu'elle est compromise et durablement
sur les dernières semaines plus de 250
mille oiseaux sont morts ou ont dû être
et aux nazis au canada
magron d'un radio canada montréal